[Music]
I'm optimistic that very soon we'll be
able to reach an agreement I've
discussed some of the outlines with my
caucus that I think we are very happy
with and hopefully the Republicans are
and and then we can get something really
good done the only reason we do not have
a full budget agreement is because
Democrats continue to hold funding for
our government hostage on an unrelated
issue if we don't change the legislation
if we don't get rid of these loopholes
we're killers are allowed to come into
our country and continue to kill we
don't change it let's have a shutdown
will do a shutdown and it's worth it for
our country I'd love to see a shutdown
if we don't get this stuff taken care of
pretty spicy words there from all over
the hill today on that issue meanwhile
right now live on the House floor you
were watching as they are voting on this
stopgap spending much or another
short-term measure to get us to March
23rd we'll keep an eye on that vote and
keep you updated let's bring in our
panel to help us do that Fox News media
analyst Howard Kurtz author of the new
book media madness Donald Trump the
press and the war over the truth Rachel
bade congressional reporter for Politico
and Jonathan Swan national political
reporter for Axios great to see all of
you okay so there's a lot of
back-and-forth on this issue the
president said his words again I'd love
to see a shutdown if we don't get this
taken care of Jonathan who got blamed
last time who will get blamed this time
Democrats very clearly got blamed last
time and I think regret some of them
anyway regret the way that it panned out
I mean this time if President Trump
keeps saying this it's very hard I then
I think for the Republicans to claim
that it's a democratic shutdown I made a
few phone calls after those comments to
try and figure out what happened was
there a grand strategy behind it it
seems not the consensus seems to be that
it was an emotional reaction and you
know it's been hearing about deaths of
people at the hands of illegal
immigrants so I don't know that this was
a particularly strategic comment made by
the president because the conversation
today at the White House including in
the briefing was about the ms-13 gang
and outlining some of these really
horrific cases the people who've lost
their lives people forget like the
president really means this stuff like
this is one of the issues the
and trade immigration he really cares
about this stuff and he's thought about
it for years it's not like health care
where he hasn't really had fully formed
thoughts he really does believe what he
says on this issue he does it's
something original he talked about all
through the campaign's way early in the
primaries all the way through it was
something people seem to really respond
to when he would talk about it in these
crowds and in these campaign events but
today when he brought it up you
immediately heard the Democrats say
that's what he wants he wants another
shutdown and they're calling it the
Trump shutdown the last one even though
the Republicans tried to name it the
Schumer or shutdown which is a little
bit snappier but they're still trying to
blame each other over the last one yeah
look I don't think it's gonna come down
to shutdown this Friday lawmakers on
both sides of the aisle even though the
president made these remarks are saying
they're gonna pass a short-term spending
stopgap and look the timing of this is
particularly interesting because
Republican leaders in the House and
Senate have been trying for months to
get Democrats to drop their demands for
a bipartisan daca fix in order to do a
long-term budget deal that gives the
military stability a huge priority for
President Donald Trump and it sounds
like the Democrats are about to cave on
that this week and this is a huge deal
it's a huge victory for Republicans if
they can get Democrats to vote for a
long-term budget agreement without a fix
for daca and the president coming in and
saying let's shut the government down it
has a lot of Republicans even scratching
their heads at that house Jenna and the
press is playing the president's remarks
about shutdown as a big threat it's not
it's a poke
it's baiting the Democrats there's not
going to be a shutdown president I think
probably knows that I'm not saying he
wasn't sincere in his comments but we
have just been through the Democrats
played that card and and it wasn't
successful also though the president
knows politically speaking that although
there's broad support in the country for
the dreamers there is not for shutting
the government down over this issue so
the Democrats have to decide whether
they would rather have some kind of
immigration compromise if indeed that's
possible to have one that would pass
both houses or whether they'd rather
have the issue to campaign on in 2018
okay so let's move on to another hot
topic we touched on this today this
issue of daca immigration of ms-13 of
folks who've lost their lives at the
hands of allegedly in this case we're
going to talk about an illegal immigrant
the Colts player and his uber driver who
were killed this weekend by a man who
reportedly was driving drunk he's here
illegally has been deported twice before
the president tweeting on this today so
disgraceful that a person illegally in
our country killed Colts linebacker
Edwin Jackson this is just one of many
such preventable tragedies we must get
the Dems to get tougher on the border
and with the illegal immigration fast
we've got a new Fox News poll that looks
at this how concerned are you about
illegal immigration 64% say extremely or
very versus 34% say not very or not at
all I mean Rachel people agree it's a
problem they don't exactly agree on the
solutions yeah I think that it's sort of
the same thing that you were mentioning
in terms of Democrats wanting a solution
for dreamers but not wanting to shut the
government down over that same thing
with illegal immigration in the country
by and large you know they want a
solution for this but again not the
expense of shutting down the government
look the president today is talking
specifically in this terrible tragedy
with the Colts player about loopholes
that Republicans have been talking about
for weeks now they say that illegal
immigrants are often deported they come
back find a way back and they basically
live here this is an example of what we
saw with this person who killed this
player so Republicans want to do
something about that it's controversial
for Democrats they're willing to talk
about border wall money but when it
comes to actual immigration policies and
actually picking people up and pushing
them out of the country that gets a
little more tenuous I guess for
Democrats it's also an issue that polls
just miss and the reason for that is the
intensity like if you are basically in
favor of more high-skilled visas
expansionist immigration policy the kind
of policies that the donor class and the
establishment DC support but Donald
Trump's base does not they're not on the
whole supporting it with the same
intensity as Donald Trump's based feel
about immigration how much they care
about illegal immigrants and wanting to
deport some of these people the level of
intensity and passion is so different
and we saw that in the gang of eight
fight they spent so much more money the
people supporting the gang of eight than
these immigration restriction escapes
and yet the the other side won in their
dinky little offices in DC with no donor
money no establishment support they won
that fight and because there's a lot of
public passion about that issue
want to talk about another top story
that the president often talks about not
so much in the last couple days but it's
excessive the stock Mart market here
eating all kinds of new highs since he
was sworn in and how he today after a
couple of really rough days that
finished up 567 points where do we go
from here
hopefully crawling back toward you know
the market was oversold and a lot of
people were expecting a correction but
it's just fascinating I've been saying
on the air as the market that went to
24,000 25,000 26,000 that the press
doesn't give the president much credit
for the soaring stock market and in
truth it's a shorthand there's a lot of
factors in the economy that go into
stock prices but I said they were if the
market had gone down that much he would
be blamed and we did see that happening
on Friday and on Thursday and yesterday
and so it seems to me that press ought
to be a little bit more consistent here
at the same time president has played a
leading role and talking up the stock
market is a major badge of success for
his economic policies when you do that
you know never will be there are these
drops sometimes these plunges and he
kind of has to own this one even though
he hasn't publicly addressed it the
White House saying today and yesterday
they believe the fundamentals
underpinning the economy are still
strong and they're gonna stay focused on
the long term events that play out here